who are you
you know who i am
i do
you're friendly neighborhood spider-man
i'm very excited very very excited i'm a
little nervous for the first day but i'm
ready to go
toby reportedly beat out freddie prince
jr jude law and james franco for the
role we have a great script to go from
we have great actors like a then 18 year
old kirsten dunst as mary jane she's
spiderman's you know love of his life
how cool is that toby and kiersten's
undeniable on-camera chemistry led to
historic scenes like this
[Music]
turns out the make-out wasn't as magical
behind the scenes
the conditions weren't as sexy and sweet
and romantic as it came off rain was
pouring up my nose and then she was
kissing me and i couldn't breathe out of
my mouth and i had to hold my breath
while i was kissing her and i would
sneak little breaths out of the corner
of my mouth it was like he was giving me
cpr or something like that
you are
amazing i don't recommend kissing that
way
and especially in the pouring rain when
you're freezing at like 5 a.m you're not
in a kissy mood still it was nice
kissing her i managed to sneak some
pleasure out of it maybe that's because
the two had a real-life romance brewing
offset toby and kirsten started dating
in 2001 while filming but by the time
the movie came out it was a different
story i swear to god we're just friends
well
see ya
now the wet kiss wasn't the only
difficulty toby faced in that spandex
spidey suit i would get uncomfortable
sometimes in that you know it was a
little bit of a process getting out of
it so if i
got a little thirsty you know i would
take me a little while to get out of it
because the zippers would break and they
would sew me into the suit the body
hugging red and blue number was custom
made for toby using body casts and
computer scans you stand there for hours
while they do different sections of your
body and
they peel it off you and rip lots of
hair out of your body and it's
excruciatingly painful now get this
ironically toby is claustrophobic but he
never let that get in the way of his
superhero duties he even did some stunts
i'm not big into spins or loops but
drops i'm okay with
is that you
and even kirsten got in on the action
i'd be in a harness and they'd bring me
to the top and drop me down and they do
a countdown too they're like one two
three and you know you're gonna drop
like and it gives you a rush every time
as for what gave toby his rush i did
have moments when i was walking to the
set or
uh on the sound stage that it was kind
of
strange and surreal or somebody would
just do a double take and go a
spider-man over there hey what's up
spider-man
[Music]